يضحكون
أنهم دخلوا الملعب مما تسبب في رفرف،
هناك العديد من الآباء في الملعب، اثنان على وجه
الدقة، الإضاءة مجرد
طيور رائعة وإخافة
لاعبات الكرة اللينة للسيدات
في ملعب جامعة سنترال فلوريدا مما
تسبب في
تأخير الحكم للمطر، نعم ولكن الببغاوات بعيدة،
هذا  بالتأكيد كانت الفرصة الأولى منذ سنوات
هي أن حكم الفريق المضيف سجل هدفه
في
دقيقة واحدة شعرت بالرياح القادمة من
الأجنحة واللهاث من الجمهور، دعنا نذهب
إلى الإعادة، لقد هبط أحد الأشخاص للتو في
الأعلى، وكان تشاد غير منزعج للغاية لدرجة أنه تظاهر
بارتداء قميصه  قناع وكأنه يستأنف اللعبة
مع ببغاء عليه عندما حاول
لمس الطائر تراجع الببغاء إلى
الكتف الآخر من هم هؤلاء
الطيور الغامضة تيكي الذي تعب في النهاية
وقرر الهبوط على
الحكم ميغان براون يملك تيكي  وليلو
كانت تسمح لهم بالطيران بحرية خلف
الملعب، كانوا دائمًا يعودون مرحبًا يا عزيزتي
أثناء مقابلتنا، قام الوالدان
بخلع نظارتها
وهاجموا العدسة ونقروا عليها، مرحبًا ليلو
وجلس على رأس ميغان،
يقول إنها مندهشة قليلاً لأن تيكي
لم يقم بقضم العدسة  عندما لمسه الحكم وهو
في عمر الثمانية أشهر،
كان عادة ما يكون نوعًا ما،
لكن تشاد أحب تيكي، لقد كانت
مجرد لحظة رائعة بعد حوالي نصف
دقيقة، حيث قام أحد أفراد الطاقم باستدراج
الطائر إليه ورافق تيكي إلى خارج الملعب.  لقد
أزعجه زملاء الحكم اليوم
وهذا يجلس على مكتبي، تعرف من
يهتم باستدعاء الكرات والضربات
عندما تكون هدفًا
لجينموس طائر سي إن إن نيويورك،
ما الذي يحدث الآن